back now at eight thirty six with
education nation today this morning how
technology is leading to a new kind of
learning NBC's Craig Melvin is here with
a look at the classroom of the future
hey Craig good morning David good
morning to you Savannah good morning to
you as well from textbooks to tablets
have you ever wondered what our
classrooms will look like 10 20 even 50
years from now well some innovative
thinkers are unlocking new and powerful
ways to teach our kids changing the way
we look at our education system in the
process
the numbers alone are staggering the
thing about the education system is it's
a very impersonal system it's a factory
model one student drops out of high
school every 26 seconds roughly thirty
percent of kids each year will not
graduate from high school that's 1.3
million in all falling through the
cracks of our education system worldwide
the numbers grow exponentially a
whopping eighty percent of kids will not
get a high school diploma experts say
each of those kids is a lost opportunity
how many da vinci's and Einsteins and
Marie Curie's and Michael Jordan's are
we losing every generation because we're
just not giving them the opportunities
that that some of us have but what if
that could be changed what if an
internet connection was the difference
in getting a world class education today
education is having that Internet moment
and a chosen few are taking some bold
steps forward I'm shows a ferrer the
founder and CEO of Newton we're trying
to revolutionize education across the
globe Newton is an adaptive learning
platform that personalizes education
based on each kid strengths and
weaknesses in essence students go at
their own pace and the software
continuously adapts to their learning
style if you learn math best with medium
difficulty practice questions we know
that if you learn science best and 24
minute bite sizes we know that everybody
has a learning experience that is unique
to them for rare started the company in
2008 using his credit card since then
Newton has grown by leaps and bounds
they currently reach almost 5 million
students and that number is growing we
want to end the access problem for
education we want every kid whether
you're in the inner city or in the
developing world we want you to have the
best possible education you can get
my name is Sal Khan and I'm the founder
of the Khan Academy in 2004 Sal Khan was
tutoring his cousins remotely from his
then home in Boston the lessons started
over the phone until a friend suggested
he upload educational videos to youtube
and I immediately said no you know
videos and YouTube that's for for cats
playing piano not serious mathematics
but I gave it a shot and those videos
took on a life of their own those videos
became the cornerstone of Khan Academy a
virtual library of now more than 4,000
tutorials covering everything from basic
math to college level chemistry our goal
over the next 5 10 50 500 years is to go
from the six million students that we're
serving every month now to 60 million
six hundred million students one of
those students recently sent Khan a
video message from the unlikeliest of
places in orphanage in Mongolia hey so
your Christmas so interesting and funny
make more messes that by itself is
pretty mind-blowing for us this idea
that the work that we get to do get can
reach people as far as an orphanage in
Mongolia two companies led by two
visionaries both using the reach of
technology to reimagine the future of
Education and a Newton recently
partnered with education publisher
houghton mifflin harcourt as a result
more kids will have access to their
adaptive learning platform and we should
note Khan Academy's mission statement
changing education for the better by
providing a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere that means all of
their tutorial videos are free of charge
as pretty cool great stuff great model
Thank You mr. Deasy I'm looking forward
to seeing you dance in a few minutes 20
well you never know